what is happening reject nation my name
is Gregory the alba my name is John 'old
the humph
and I moccasin Akasaka son so aqus on
this a couple of disclaimers we gotta
make really quick yeah it's the first
time here on this thank you for having
me yes you've been on the real rejects
before but it was a sketchy or was
honest guy that was a documentary found
footage of real events something we did
and that's exactly what well I'm I know
what you're alluding to because that was
exactly what the fans wanted us to do
you know for me coming all the way over
to I was told by a YouTube consultant to
not call followers and subscribers Oh
fans oh really
it's causes a separation rule we prefer
to call them members of our intimate
family yes okay YouTube's not me I don't
believe at all people John moved in
birthday yesterday was congratulations
and now we're on the bearer back on the
couch
no more office chairs goodbye to the
office not do reactions last time we did
it my understanding is you are known as
the black man from Japan this is true
the only black man ever to live in Japan
so there's a Japanese movie out okay I
think it's the Japanese but we call
blade of the immortal this is true yes I
saw it on some movie sites a girl I had
one minor sexual encounter with told me
to go watch this trailer - really and
and I saw tyro and reacted to it we know
- I rose well yeah he's the black man
from New Jersey yeah and now we're gonna
watch blade at the Porco's this is the
longest interest if I roll
I was playing around with Anita star who
is actually well and she actually called
me yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
Wow
don't oh that's dope I like that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh that's gonna be a sick 5/100 of food
[Applause]
how many oh my goodness is actually
pretty sick God looks those goes so cool
that was awesome man I mean I can only
imagine where everyone now is really
stunning young the action looks amazing
I like that it's just a simple story
it's a simple story of vengeance for
some it was cool Japanese like
supernatural elements yes man who
doesn't die the characters look badass
female badass male bad ah then it's
everything I would want in a cool
samurai flick and visually updated
though man right basically update you're
talking about update uh updated Nasseri
current with kind of like the trailers
like I was kind of comparing it to the
black panther yeah yeah it had that like
Browns but it has that sound tractor in
the back that really worked well with
yeah this movie and then on top of that
for a lot of foreign films you're always
gonna get subtitles at the bottom that
works yeah well before because for me I
obviously understood what they were
saying but to have it in the background
like that really work yeah yeah I'd love
to see subtitles incorporated like that
in the future I wonder if that's just
for the trailer though or if that's for
the actual movie itself that's a good
question because for having a first
trailer I can see them doing it's kind
of like a Tony Scott used to do
subtitles in some movies
a good question but I think they would
have to improve the animation a little
bit because I do look like trailer
sometimes okay yeah first as creative as
the Reisman is like some edges I didn't
know that either yeah
that did it was interesting reminded me
a lot of Kill Bill as well kind of like
where it was going but don't be American
I'm sorry don't this is always say this
reminds you of Kill Bill
this is Kill Bill was inspired by things
like this fair enough kiss on okay
you're making us look bad I can't for
the life of me remember what the name of
the movie was but I went to the new Bev
once and I watched you know like an old
it Judah killer it no I wasn't I wasn't
one of his it was like a random samurai
grindhouse action movie okay you know
it's like period piece
this is dude off in the woods and lots
of limbs and stuff getting hacked off
but you know still very old-school and
like this reminded me of that and I was
like you know cuz Kill Bill is very
modern very good got a guy Stern also so
similar to like Ninja Scroll or so yeah
this looks more traditional narrative
like especially when his hand reattached
with a little tentacle yeah that reminds
me of like anime imagery that we can now
like make live-action yeah so I'm
excited to see the return of this style
but with you know the blood and stuff
that we add now oh yeah this one looks
fantastic it 400th film that's crazy I
don't want to looks like he cares is
this hundred film as funny is when the
Kill Bill trailer came out it always
said the fourth so for second I was like
are they gonna name drop Tarantino the
way they did that but it was not now I
wonder if it's a Kashia meek has had a
bunch of interviews where he's like I'm
gonna stop at a hundred films that was a
really badass trailer listen I'm gonna
wrap this video up right about now
subscribe to the really Jax I love doing
outros click that notification bell
you'll ignore it it's okay dad John
Humphrey on Twitter and Instagram E and
a cuss on Uncas on Coulson okay she
needs something yeah follow
aqus on on YouTube he was the one who
first started free actors knowing each
other ya know please look we're headed
toward the future of yellow dollar marks
and D monetization I'm so excited for
that that's why you should subscribe now
so you can get unsubscribe without
asking and don't forget our patreon
don't forget our page very important so
one thing that allows us to keep our
channels in production